[موسيقى]
مساء الخير للجميع يعطيكم الف عافيه طبعا
دوري كان اخر واحد ففاجئوني انه دوري الان
بدي شوي تشجيعه
[تصفيق]
واحد من اغرب الدروع اللي عندي هو دوره
بعنوان كيف تضيع بالصحراء انا مجدي اشتغلت
سنه ونصف بتضيع الناس في الصحراء كنت
حرفيا
بضيعهم وبرجعهم فقط عن طريق النجوم فبشوف
النجوم بشوف الاتجاهات فبعرف من خلالها
لدرجه سميت اولادي عندي البكر مطر والتوام
كون وفلك
بصراحه اليوم اغلب اللي موجودين كان قصص
جدا رهيبه كانوا بيحكي عن النجاح لكن انا
اليوم بدي احكي عن قصص اخرى راح احكي شوي
عن قصص الفشل او خلينا نحكي بطريقه شوي
مختلفه
باول مره بدخل فيها مدينه عمان كانت في
2011 قبلها كنت سكان العقبه في عندي اربع
صور موجوده على الشاشه شايفينها هايا اطرف
الاشياء اذا صارت معي باول سن دخوليه
الجامعه فاول سنه كنت بعرفش عمان
معرف حدا فيها نهائيا فسكت بعجلون
وكنت كل بدايه صباحا بطلع على عمان بداوم
الجامعه واخر يوم برجع باول يوم دوام وصلت
صويلح لقيت باص مكتوب عليه السلطانيه فقلت
وصلت الجامعه طلعت على الباص وبدا ما
نزلنا على الجامعه نزلني على السلط وهاي
كانت اول تجربه الي في المواصلات العامه
داخل مدينه عمان الصوره اللي بعدها
طبعا والدي كان اصلي موجود لكن ما زالوا
بالطريق درست عن طريق المكرمه الملكيه
السامه كاد دراسه كلها عن طريق الجيش
فبدايه الفصل بتدفع من جيبتك واخر السنه
او اخر الفصل بيرجعوا لك الفلوس
فرجعوا لي 700 دينار من هنا فوالد كانت
متوقع انه يوصلون فسحبت حالي على كارفور
واشتريت اول كاميرا بحياتي
الصوره اللي بعدها اشتغلت في مجال التدريب
اذا بتلاحظوا بحكي كثير بسرعه
ودربت على التصوير باول دور بحياتي كنت
مجهز ماده لتخلص بخمس ايام لاني بحكي
بسرعه خلصت اول نصف ساعه هذا
معي ساعتين الدوره وعندي اربع ايام زياده
شو بدي اعمل فيهم طلعت ولما رجعت صرت شو
اعمل اتعلم وثم اعلم وهنا تعلمت اشي جديد
بحياتي اذا اردت ان تتعلم فعليك ان تعلم
فواحد من الطرق اللي بستخدم عشان اتعلم
اشي جديد بطلع فيها دوره وبعلم فيها ناس
عشان اكسب العلم من خلالها نيجي على اخر
صوره هاي اول مقابله على التلفزيون بصراحه
اكثر مقابله للشباب بتذكروني فيها لما
طلعت على التلفزيون مذيعه بتسالني بدنا
اسئله خليني ارتجال ارتجال انا مجدي يعني
ارتجال الموضوع سهل
المذيعه بتسال بتسال فاجات عن سؤال شو
اللي بميز شو اللي بيميز مجدي عن غيره
طلعت عليها طلعت على السقف رجعت طلعت
عليها رجعت على السقف
شو اللي بميز عن غيره سؤال جديد يعني
وما زال الشباب ماخذين مقطع وكل ما يصير
موقف شو اللي بميت عن غيره بتطلع فوق فش
عندك جواب وهيك كانت دخوله لعمان فدخلت
عمان ما حدا كان بيعرفني حاليا اليوم
الحمد لله موجود على عم بحكي عن قصه نجاح
لما حكينا على الجامعه نرجع الفتره اللي
قبل الجامعه انا انسان مثل ما قلت لكم لم
اعش في عمان قطعا وانما عشت في مدينه
العقبه هي الدوله او هي دوله هي المحافظه
اللي عشت فيها حياتي كامله
فكنت بلعب تنس طاوله خسرت بالدوله النهائي
على المملكه كنت بلعب شطرنج خسرت على
مستوى المحافظات كانت كل حياتي مبنيه على
ملك الشباب العقبه كنا يوميا نطلع عليهم
نتعلم اشي جديد وكل نهايه اسبوع لمده 6
اشهر كنا خميس جمعه سبت في محافظه بس
بنعسكر ونتعلم شو جديد فعشرين سنه كامله
في العقبه وليس في عمان نمشي الصفحه اللي
بعدها بدي احكي شوي عن حياتكم مصور انا
كنت مصور متخصص فيه
باخر مرحله تصوير الحمد لله في معي اكثر
من 10 جوائز محليه ودوليه مركز اول لكن
لما كنا نصور كنت انا مصور الطبيعه فاذا
تشوفوا هاي وحده من الصور اللي غرقت فيها
بالطين وما قدرت اطلع نهائيا طين فاجا
شباب سحبوني
تقدرنا نطلع هاي الصوره كنا لما نسمع في
عاصفه الناس
كنا بنطلع بنروح نتسلق الجبال حتى نصور
صوره اللي صورتها براس النقب وقت اخر ثلجه
اوكي مشروع تخرجي مشروع تخرجي كان شوي
حبيت اعمل اشي غريب فرحت جبت حذاء وبليت
عليه وحطيته بالكليه الفنون التصميم فصار
كل واحد بيمشي على الكليه بتطلع
احضر مشروع تخرجي
حدا عمرك كتب على جوجل الشاب اردني يعرف
تمام قبل فتره او قبل تقريبا وقت الكورونا
وما حولها فدخلنا انا والشباب بموضوع نقاش
انه هل الانسان سهل ينتشر ويشهر حاله فقلت
له الموضوع انك تشرح حالك في الاردن موضوع
بسيط بلدنا صغيره كنا بنعرف بعض فمجتمعنا
كثير صغير وهذا الشيء بيسمح لاي واحد
ينتشر بشكل كبير جدا
فكتبت مقاله عرضت مجموعه من صوري
وعرضت صوره حذاء للبيع وحطيت سعره فبعد ما
حددت سعره اكتشفت انه صار ترند وصارت كل
العالم بيحكوا عنه مع انه حتى الخبر
السحري كتبته انا فموضوع انك تنتشر
بالاردن الموضوع جدا بسيط كله عليك بس
شويه جده بالضحك كان مجموعه مواضيع صراحه
احكي عنها اليوم مش عن قصص السابقه بتحكي
عن مجموعه قواعد انا متخذ بحياتي اول
قاعده هي قاعده دقيقتين هاي القاعده كثير
مشيت لي تاسكات بحياتي القاعده بتحكي لك
اذا عندك تاسك ممكن تخلص خلال دقيقتين
خلصها الان ما تاجلها ليش احنا مشكلتنا
بالحياه انه تعمل الاشي طيب ماشي بعمله
ابعت ايميل طيب احكي مع الشخص الثاني
نهايه اليوم
فانا صار لي حرفيه ما يقارب سنتين بشتغل
على القاعده انه اذا عندك مهمه ممكن تخلص
بنفس اللحظه خلصها وما بتراكبها
بدي احكي عن موضوع اخر لا تضيع اي فرصه
الحياه اللي احنا فيها حياه جدا صغيره
وانت قاعد قدامك مجموعه الفرات اهم قاعده
بالحياه اذا عده فرصه شفتها قدامك انتقل
عليها واعماله مباشره القاده بتحكي لك انه
انت موجود هنا اذا الفرصه عملتها ونجحت
فانت حتصير هون لكن لو الفرصه ما ضبطت
حترجع موجود لهون
لا تخجل من العثرات
قبل سنه ونص بالضبط وحده من الشركات
الموجوده عندي بسبب خطا مني نزلت تنفيذ
جبهه الدخل وهذا الشيء سبب لي مشكله كبيره
خلاني حرفيا اخسر شركتي اخسر موظفيني
التراكمت عليها فلوس بسبب واحد كل الدخل
اللي بيجي عليك شو عم بيصير فيه بتحطه
بالبنك بنسحب له الضريبه فعشنا فتره تمام
خسرتنا كتير ناس لكن هل هاي كسرتنا حرفيا
بعتبر الان واحد من افضل الشغلات التي
صارت بحياتي لما يسرنا وسكرنا شركتنا او
حاليا في مرحله الاغلاق وقعنا مشكله كبيره
عندنا كثير ديون فش معنا فلوس الموظفين
عنا اخترناهم المكتب سكرناهم بطل عنا
الطريق الدخل معينه فصار عندي مشكله
رئيسيه عندي اطفال عندي حياه بدي اعيشها
عندي موظفين تراكم رواتبهم اي دخل فشو
الحل بدك تشوف شوف في طرق تفتح فيها
مشاريع جديده
لما كنت كان عندي شركه كان عندي شركه عندي
راتب فالامور جميله لكن لما سكرت وقعدت
سنه ونص راتبي زيرو وكل الدخل اللي عم
بيروح وقعنا بالكارثه العظمى من وين بدنا
نجيب دخل وكيف بدنا نسكر مجموعه التزامات
من هنا الفتح الا ما كثير جديد اول اشي
عملته تركت مدينه عمان كلها وقلت لازم
ارجع اصفي حالي شوي وافصل شوي عن العالم
البزنس ورحت عشت بالعقبه وقلت راح ارجع
ابني حياتي من المرحله اللي بلش فيها وانا
صغير فرجعت ابني حياتي من الزيرو فتحنا
مجموعه مشاريع الحمد لله اخذت مجموعه من
الجوائز في كمان صفحه اوكي في كمان صفحه
بحكي عنها فتحنا مجموعه مشاريع انه تحاول
تدخن الدخل اول مشروع بلشنا فيه اخذنا
عليه جائزتين جراند اطلقنا بلاتفورم معني
بالسياحه تحت الماء وبعرف الناس على بشبك
الناس مع مراكز الغطس وهذا جوائز كونه
بدخل
والخضراء والحمايه تحت البحر دخلنا على
مشروع كيف ممكن تدخل كمان فلوس بدنا انكم
الشغل
اطلقنا اشي اسمه درون ان جوردن هي عباره
عن منصه تسمح لاي شخص يشتري مشهد جوي بدون
ما يطير طائره درون فصار عنا مصدرين للدخل
وقفنا هون لا ايش في طرق اخرى تقدر تطلع
فيها دخلنا على الطريقه شويه تفكير دائما
ناجحه ودائما بنشوفها
شركه اوبر عنده كثير حلو انه هي ما بتشتغل
بايدها هي بتشبك الاشخاص بدهم سيارات مع
الاشخاص اللي عندهم سيارات وهي واحده من
اللي الى الان ناجح اي اشي بمشي على نفس
الطريقه هو بزنس موديل ناجح فبلشنا نفكر
كيف ممكن نحول اي فكره تمام يجيب دخل بدون
ما تعمل اشي حاليا رغم انه شركتي في اغلاق
صار في عندي سبعه ستارتاب السبعه ستارتاب
كل واحد شغال كل واحد عم بجيب انكم بدون
اي تدخل مني بشكل كلي اخر شيء عملناه
فلافل
طيب شو اغلى اشتريته اوكي بطريقه ثانيه
ثلاث حبات هذا يشحنها في اليوم ثلاث حبات
فلافل مع رغيف خبز فاضي بدون لاساطه لشطه
والحمص كم بوصه سعره
ربع دينار
وصلنا في بزنس حولنا الفكره لستوري وبنينا
عليه اصبحت ثلاث حبات فلافل مع رغيف خبز
فاضي بدينار وعليه طلب جدا عالي وهون انا
بدي انهي حديثي لليوم انا مجدي القضاه
رياده اعمال
مصور ومدرب فوتوغراف دربت اكثر من 4000
طالب اول دوره اعطيتها بنص ساعه خلصتها
اخر محاضره اعطيتها ما زال الناس الى الان
بحكوا عنها ويعطيكم الف عافيه
[موسيقى]